hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and get some
zucchini crush soda level 175
walkthrough tutorial in these first two
rooms we need to get through as fast as
we can so we don't want to waste a lot
of moves setting up you know crazy
combos we just want to try to figure out
the fastest way that we can get to these
bears and you know the very first move
you could see that I picked one there
were probably some specials that could
have made that I picked the one that was
on right in front of me that I knew I
could get you get the hits on the two in
the middle and now I can set this up and
clear out a lot and get through there
pretty quickly if you get stuck like on
this board sometimes you can get through
on the second board quick but if you
gotta get hung up on both and I usually
will start over here I just want to set
up things like this stripe that'll go
right into the middle and then I can
make up and you know make another stripe
at the same time because it's sort of a
bottleneck there so you just want to get
things that are gonna hit those Bears as
fast as possible and like here you know
definitely a regular match that I'll hit
them both is great and that's a
no-brainer there to make that match and
so I'm pretty happy with that as far as
that's pretty quick to get through both
of those and then in this room where we
got a pretty good setup to start it's
the same sort of thing actually was
actually great we got through there
sometimes you'll get through the first
two pretty quick and then you'll get to
that one and get stuck and that's why
this level is really frustrating so this
is maybe the most moves ever had in this
room but that doesn't mean it's going to
be easy
the space is small and I'm gonna need to
make a lot of fish basically because I
got three bears on here the honey over
there and we got these coils in the
middle and you know basically we have to
get you know nine hits on those bears to
get them free and so now you know I've
used several moves and I haven't hit
them at all yet so I'm sure if you play
this if you're watching this video for
help and you know you can come in here
and just sometimes just get completely
stocked and there's really not a whole
lot that you can do except you know just
keep trying because like it's that it's
the space that's screwing me up and
that's the same problem you're gonna run
into so you just need to you know like
with the stripes the stripes really
aren't gonna do much and they'll take
those coils out of the way but a lot of
times I just use them to match with a
fish if I can make one and like over
here I got this fish but I can't set it
off so I'm just gonna have to work my
way down and it's fantastic to be able
to make a bomb like you really want to
if you can but a lot of times it's gonna
happen as the pieces fall at least in my
experience you know that's the way it's
gone so you just have to take advantage
of those opportunities when they happen
and yeah we're doing pretty lousy I mean
we got plenty of moves left right now
but we're getting pretty lousy run so
far you know fish on just popping right
up for us we haven't had any moms here's
a fish over here excuse me and that's
that's why you really just don't have to
try to get into this last room that this
Maine
as you can the more moves you have the
more chances you'll get and then just
try to make the best choices with what
you have to work with here again I got
enough fish that's just gonna hit it
like fish but just keep plugging away
here so we only have I mean we you know
we're in pretty good shape still we have
15 moves we have two bears that need one
hit and one bad that needs to hit so if
we could make and set off for fish or
even if we could get to finish to match
them together which would be awesome but
like like I said the kids aren't really
helping us out very much here one thing
there we go one thing to keep in mind is
you can't really make vertical stripes
that would be another great thing but
since it's only three three rows deep
you just won't get a chance to do that
alright so here like I said we got two
fish we got three bears and there we go
so um you know it's I know it's a
frustrating level I know the first time
I play it I have you know I was really
frustrated with it it seemed kind of
impossible but one of the things you
knew is if you can't get through the
first rooms you know start over if you
have to and then when you get into the
last room just take your time and I can
also tell you that I tried to set up
fish and things in the third room that
would come through and I didn't really
have any luck with that so just get
there as fast as you can and just make
fish and if they're not there set it up
so you can make something you'll
eventually get past it I hope this helps
make sure you subscribe to our channels
to support us and then you'll get you'll
know when new videos like this come out
and like the video if you found it
helpful